las consecuencias de los papeles de
pandora empiezan a llegar a las
instituciones en américa latina'
rechazan las acusaciones los tres
presidentes en el cargo implicados en la
filtración global de documentos el
ecuatoriano guillermo lasso el chileno
sebastián piñera y el dominicano luis
abinader
sin embargo ciudadanos y oposición
exigen responsabilidades la oposición
chilena ya anunció una acusación
constitucional contra piñera por el
supuesto conflicto de intereses con el
proyecto minero dominga es decir un
juicio político que podría llevar a la
destitución del presidente una
eventualidad a poco más de un mes de la
primera vuelta electoral en la cual el
mandatario no concurre a la reelección
en ecuador el jefe de la comisión de
fiscalización del congreso también
solicitó información al presidente
guillermo lasso que aparece en los
papeles de pandora por sus actividades
financieras en paraísos fiscales previas
al inicio de su carrera hacia la
presidencia
en vista que ningún legislador ha
solicitado a fiscalización que se inicie
una investigación sobre pandora papers
hoy ha pedido a guillermo lasso que
remita información del caso no sólo
investigaré pandora paper sino de
exfuncionarios en panamá papers el
principal partido de oposición
dominicano también solicitó
transparencia al presidente luís
abinader acusado de no declarar su
capital observe el pdl considera que el
pueblo dominicano merece una explicación
completa y convincente del presidente
luís abinader sobre las empresas
offshore no incluidas en su declaración
pública de bienes en los casi 12
millones de documentos filtrados
también aparecen altos cargos económicos
latinoamericanos como el ministro de
finanzas de bolsonaro paulo guedes el
director del banco central brasileño
roberto campos neto o el director de la
autoridad tributaria de colombia
lisandro junto a todos ellos y entre
otros también han sido llamados a rendir
cuentas ante los legislativos de sus
respectivos países